Today is the day that Ron DeSantis launches his
presidential campaign entering the Republican
primary against the presumed and actual it's
finally presumed he's really the front runner,
Donald Trump. And we will soon start to learn
is there some viable path for Ron DeSantis
to the Republican nomination? The details are
fascinating and abortive. Ron DeSantis is going
to be launching his campaign on Twitter right now
in a Twitter spaces event with Twitter owner Elon
Musk. NBC News reports the Florida governor will
announce he is running for president on Twitter
Wednesday evening in a conversation with Elon
musk. We will be streaming this live on youtube,
twitch and facebook. I hope you will join us for
that. NBC News explains. Musk and DeSantis will
host an event on Twitter Spaces, the site's
platform for audio chats on Wednesday at six
Eastern. It will be moderated by David Sachs,
a tech entrepreneur who's a Musk confidant and
DeSantis supporter. That same evening, meaning
tonight, the campaign will release a launch video.
DeSantis will begin visiting several early states
after Memorial Day. The relationship could could
is doing a lot of work here. The relationship
could be a significant boost for DeSantis by
giving him an introduction to and credibility
with Musk's massive following, including
his hundred and 40 million Twitter followers. But
it could prove a burden should DeSantis become
distracted by the tycoon's many controversial
comments. Not only that. I mean, listen, let's be
honest. Ron DeSantis, This entire Anti-woke thing
is not actually very much in line with Elon Musk's
Tesla electric vehicles. We're we're not going to
go rogue with these electric vehicles. You can't
even drive, right? I mean, it doesn't actually
make any sense. But also, Musk has started to
play coy with Republican elected officials
becoming buddy buddy with Greg Abbott in Texas,
etc.. So it's going to be quite a wild event and
I'm as curious as anybody else. You know, one of
the things that we have to understand Twitter
space is why. My understanding is there will be
absolutely no pushback or actual journalistic
questions asked on Twitter spaces tonight. And
that may be by design. It's not clear. DeSantis
wants to answer questions tonight, including the
most obvious and basic question, which is what is
the Santos's mathematical path to this nomination?
Because if we look at current polling, here's
the Real Clear Politics average is in the 2024
Republican presidential nomination. What you see
here, the two most important lines on this chart
are the purple line at the top, which keeps going
up. That's Donald Trump and the green line down
the middle, which keeps going down. That's
DeSantis. And DeSantis continues to see small
declines in polling now down to just 19.4. Today,
Trump's lead over DeSantis in the primary is,
I think, as big as it has ever been. I mean, at
one point it reached what looks like 32, yet Trump
is now leading DeSantis by 37 in the primary.
That's this is arguably the worst it has looked
for DeSantis since his name started to be thrown
around seriously back in September. And so the
question is, how can De Santos scoop up all of the
non-Trump vote, which would get him to 44, 43, 44?
And then if and when he does that, how does he
take. At least six or seven points from Trump
to get even with him. I don't know the answer.
You know, when we ask the question generically,
right. How does a candidate take supporters from
another candidate? There is a few ways. One is you
explain DeSantis could explain his values in a way
that would appeal to the moral beliefs of Trump
supporters, like he could frame his policies
on immigration or health care or education or
whatever. He could frame it in terms of individual
freedom or national security or being anti-woke or
whatever he thinks will appeal to MAGA people.
It doesn't really sound likely. It doesn't sound
to me that MAGA voters are they're waiting for
someone else to appeal to them on the moral values
that attracted them to Trump just doesn't seem
to really make sense. Second possibility to take
support from a candidate that already has support
would be Can you gather up enough endorsements
from influential, enough figures that Trump
supporters trust and respect that they say,
Hey, you know what? It's less about Trump and
DeSantis. It's the people that I see endorsing
DeSantis makes me makes me think I should leave
Trump and go to DeSantis. It again, doesn't seem
likely because we just looked at this story. More
than 100 former Trump officials are supporting
DeSantis. We've seen a number of prominent
Republicans say we need a different direction
than Trump. MAGA genuinely doesn't seem to care.
So that doesn't seem like a path for DeSantis to
take support from Trump. And then the third way
you can take support away from someone who has it
is you make a mathematical case, you make
an empirical case, you make a polling case,
and you say, I am the person that is best
positioned to beat Joe Biden. You convince
MAGA people. With Trump, you lose to Biden. With
me, you win. I honestly don't even know that
that would convince MAGA voters, even if it's
true. Because on Friday in the Friday feedback
segment we're going to look at emails from Trump
cultists who say, I don't care about anything,
I will only vote for Trump. And that's it. And
so that also doesn't seem to be a convincing
argument that DeSantis could make to take support
for Trump. And again, remember, the reason this
matters is Trump's already polling 56. So to win,
DeSantis has to take supporters from Trump. I
don't know how he does it. So we're going to look
at the event tonight. We'll see what happens.
Should be interesting. We'll see what role Elon
Musk plans to play in the DeSantis campaign more
broadly. It seems as though with Musk behind him,
Twitter is going to be potentially a strong force
supporting DeSantis. But would that be enough?
Would that make a difference? We will see in
the meantime. Trump brown posers and suck
ups are starting to do the dirty work for
Trump in attacking Ron DeSantis. One of those
people is Kari Lake. Let's talk about that next